les interrogations devraient être levés
avec un homme que l'on va retrouver
demain la tête de l'egypte
un homme que l'on connaît mal c'est le
vice président hosni moubarak lundi il
sera vraisemblablement élu président lui
qui a toujours été aux côtés d'anouar el
sadate tel son ombre on le voyait
partout à côté de sa dague y compris
hier lors du fatal défilé de l'armée
moubarak comme sadate est un militaire
moubarak comme sadate est né dans un
village du delta du nil c'est un
aviateur formé d'abord en egypte puis à
moscou à l'académie militaire foods est
l'équivalent de l'école de guerre
française s'adapte à nommer en 1972
commandant en chef de l'armée de l'air
égyptienne en remplacement d'un général
qui se plaignait de la présence de
conseil militaire soviétique en egypte
aubrac ses destinées de ces destins gay
dans la guerre de 1973 contre israël
en 1975 il est devenu brusquement hommes
politiques lorsque sa date l'a choisie
comme vice-président tout de suite on
lui confia démission diplôme est
délicate elle que la médiation entre
maroc algérie et mauritanie à propos du
sahara espagnol
c'est lui aussi qui lui la tâche ardue
d'aller expliquer dans plusieurs
capitales arabes
les modalités de l'accord d'armistice
avec israël il fit ensuite plusieurs
missions diplomatiques moins difficile
aux etats-unis nous voyons ici les plus
présents carter et tout récemment en
france aujourd'hui l'umq monsieur
moubarak est candidat officiel du parti
national démocrate à la succession de
sadate à la présidence de l'egypte tout
en restant à la tête des forces armées
égyptiennes s'est et répétons le
monsieur taleb président du parlement
qui est président par intérim jusqu'à
l'élection du successeur de sadate
[Musique]